[Music]
hi everyone and welcome to the channel
in this video we're gonna build a react
game and i wanted to build one of those
sliding puzzles
where you have 16 tile spaces and one of
them is empty
so you can slide the other tiles around
sometimes they use
numbers to see that you get them in the
correct order
i wanted to make it a bit customizable
so that you could set your own image
and have that image as the puzzle
so let's jump into the implementation
[Music]
okay so let's get on with building this
react sliding puzzle
so i have prepared some code here
that we're going to use as a starting
point and it's only the ui
so the important files are
the board the board has tiles
and i put on the game logic
or like helper functions for the game
logic inside helpers
and i also prepared some functions there
that i have tested out beforehand
and then of course i did the styling so
what we have right now
looks like this it's not functional it's
only the visuals
done because i wanted to get that out of
the way so we can focus on
building the actual game and the game
logic
so if we look at how the styling works
i'm just centering everything inside the
app
i i have the board
which is using
i think this flex is maybe
unnecessary as well yeah the flex is not
doing anything
so inside the board the tiles are being
positioned
absolute and this
is just for centering the number inside
each square so that's the styling
if we look inside the board component
i set up a little piece of state here to
keep track of all the tiles
i calculate the size of
each tile based on the board size
and here we see that these uppercase
snake cased variables they are our
constants
and they come from this file so we just
have the board size
the grid size like how many tiles are in
the rows and columns
and the total tile count so those are
imported
so we make a style object here that we
place
on the board so it gets the correct
width and height
and then we start to map through each of
the tiles
and then we use the tile component and
what we pass
in is the index the
some
[Music]
the corresponding tile we pass in
and the width and the height of the
piece
so let's jump in oh there's also a start
game button here but it has no
functionality yet
so now let's let's jump into the tile
component
so here are the props that i mentioned
and maybe before we jump into the tile
component
we should go through the helper
functions that i have
done beforehand so it's
also important some of the constants
here
and here i found a neat function from a
similar project
and i wanted to link it here
to give credit to them as well because
they also made a nice implementation of
this but i changed mine
a little bit so it's solvable
that is because when we randomize the
board
we want to make sure that it's solvable
still and if it's not solvable we just
randomize again
here's a helper function to check if for
the win condition
here is a function where we can pass in
a row and a column
basically coordinate and we can get the
index of that one basically giving us
the number of the tile but
of course minus one since the index
starts at zero
here we have a function called get
matrix position
and that will pass back an object with
the row and column
for a specified index so that is
basically the same as get index but
backwards
here is a helper function to get the
visual position and that is because
we're absolutely going to absolute
or we are absolute positioning the tiles
so we need to calculate what each
position
has in pixels
and here is our shuffle function
so we shuffle the tiles here is the the
sort by
random so it shuffles them up
and checks if it's solvable and that
it's not
giving us the already solved mix
and then returning the shuffle tiles
here is a helper function to check if we
can swap
tiles basically are you pressing a tile
adjacent to the empty slot or not
and here is the function that actually
does the swap of the tiles that moves
the tile into the empty slot
and here is another helper function that
we're going to use in the
end because i want to
have the functionality that we can
specify our own
image and use that as the background
instead of just having
this red background and these numbers i
want to have the functionality of using
your own
image to make it a little bit more fun
so this function we can use that later
to
update the image as a url parameter
because what that allows us to do is to
pass a link to someone
and have them play the game with an
image that we choose in our link
so basically you add your own image and
you copy the link
send to a friend and then can play with
whatever image you've chosen
and that's it for the helper functions
so now we have a good starting point to
to implement
the react functionality to get this all
to work
so let's start at the board
we see here that in order to create the
tiles
we take an empty array these brackets
here
we instantiate an array
with the length of the tile count
and we spread it out in here
that gives us an array of the correct
size
and of course one of the first
things that we want to do is that we
when we start the game we want to
shuffle all the tiles
because now they are they are in a
solved order
because we're just creating this array
here
so we will create a function inside this
component
called shuffle
tiles
and this one
now we need to import that function from
helpers and what did we call it we
called it
just shuffle and we should pass in the
tiles
so we import shuffle
from
dash helpers
there we go now we have shuffle shuffle
and the tiles
and then once we shuffle the tiles
and we know that we get a nice shuffle
from this from what i mentioned earlier
so we get back the shuffle tiles and
then we
call a set state
so we set the tiles to these shuffled
tiles
this is now this is now a little
function we can use to
now we connect this helper function to
the state of the
react app so that that's great
we should also have a function for when
we click a tile
to get it to to swap places
so we'll call that swap tiles
so now we're gonna write our swap titles
function
and first we're gonna check
with the can swap function is if we can
swap that tile
and so let's look at the can swap
so we're supposed to pass a source
index and the destination index
so the tile index passed in here
is the tile that has been clicked on
so can swap
the first the source is tile index the
one that's been clicked on
and the empty tile is always the last
one
we're using tile 16.
type 16 is always the empty one so we
just have to pass
tile stop length
minus one so we'll check
can the clicked on tile move
to the position where the last tile is
remember this has been shuffled
so the empty slot will be somewhere and
we're making sure that we press
a tile that can move into that position
of the empty one
so if we can then we can call the swap
so let's look at the swap function so we
we're supposed to pass all the tiles
and the source and destination
and this is also indexes
so we'll pass tiles and then
tile index and tile
start playing minus one
that should swap the tile into that
position
and i think from that we
get all the tiles back so
we need to save what we get back from
this
just swap tiles
and then we need to set tiles
to swapped tiles
so hopefully that should work as well
we should have a separate function
to handle the click of the tile handle
tile click
this is the first function that will be
called once a tile is clicked
and that one gets the index
of the tile clicked
index
so we call we try to call swap tiles
and just pass along the index
and let's make a similar one to handle
shuffle click
and this one does not have to take any
parameters
and here we call shuffle tiles
so now we have these two functions
we need to attach them to
i think this one will be attached to
like a shuffle button
and this one will be attached to
tiles that we click when we play the
game
we should have a piece of state
to check if um if we solve the game or
not
solve
use the state
and the default should be false
and probably let's also have
this started
so that because why we have is started
is so that we can show
the finished puzzle before
someone starts the game so you can see
what you're aiming for or memorize a bit
what the image looks like
let's try to keep it as one button but
we can change the behavior of the button
dependent
on the is started and so on
so if it's not started we can just have
this
a start game button so
is started
if it started is true then also render
this start game button
and we add an on click to that one
with
i mean these small functions you can
choose to have them just
in line here if you want to
and
start click so inside this one
we want to first shuffle the tiles
and then set the game to start it so
shuffle tiles and then set
is started
to true
and if we are started
actually this should be if we're not
started we should show this button
and then we can do it like this if it's
started
we show this button
and then we can make a ternary operator
to show
another button
so if we're not started we show the
start game button
if we are already started we can show a
restart
game button and then
we don't have to
then we can call the handle shuffle
click because if we restart the game
all we have to do is reshuffle the game
basically
so handle shuffle click
so the first time you click start game
it shuffles
and it says the start to true
and if you restart the game you only
shuffle the tiles
so now we're using both of these
functions here
so this last function handle tile click
that one we want to pass into a tile
so that the tile can use it
handle tile click
and type click
okay great so now we have some of the
logic here
so let's validate that it works
is started so we console log
is started here and let's make a little
note of
what we're console vlogging please
started
so let's go to our console here
we might have an error maybe
let's see what errors we have so far
maybe some unused variables
tile is not defined so tiles is not
defined
tiles should be and swapped tiles
in on line 20
so tiles
and now we just have two unused
variables
so now we can actually see that the
starter is false and we press start gain
it does shuffle it and
it changes to restart game and if i
press restart game
it should shuffle the board again
that's great perfect
so what we've done so far seems to work
we can start the game
we can shuffle the game
so now we can move into the tile
so we need first to handle the entire
handle tile click so we
receive that as a prop
handle tile click
and we should attach that to
the tile itself so
only click
and we'll tile clip and we should pass
in
the index and that one we did get from
the tile here
index
so no errors so now let's try clicking
one
yeah it almost seemed to work it worked
for the my first click
but not more than once so you're
probably close but there must be some
error somewhere something is wrong
with the swap tiles
so can swap must evaluate the true the
first time at least
let's console log them and see what
happens
so
the first time it did work and the
second time
nothing happens okay so i think i
understand the error
now the the index of the last tile
will change so instead of just passing
in the last one all the time
we should do tile stop dot index off
so we're basically searching for the
index
of number 15 in the list
because what i saw from here was that
if the la the open slot
switches then it doesn't have the last
index anymore so
when we do tile tiles.indexof
then we're searching in the list for the
index of 15
instead of just passing in the last
spot that's why it only worked the first
time
so let's try this again
oh it's the same thing here actually
so now let's try no it
works much better
so let's see if i can move 15 up to the
beginning here
yeah seem to work okay
so now the swap titles seem to work
but you might have seen that i can
start to play the game from
the start state but we should check if
the game has been started
because otherwise you can just do this
and then you're done
but let's wait with doing that because
we want to
test the wind condition and it's very
easy for us to test the win condition
if the game is already started
in at this stage
i think we don't even need this to be a
piece of state because
we're not gonna call set is sold
we can just derive that by using our
helper function
so let's remove that piece of state and
instead
we just set a constant here
is solved
and then the import
is solved from this helper
function we import it's all from the
helpers
and we do is solved
i guess we pass in the tiles
yeah we just pass in the tiles
so here we can do is solve
and we're gonna add a check for a
started here but let's first
just do it with only a salt
we can add this started after because
then we can check that the salt actually
works
parcel solid
let's add some fun emoji as well
so let's see if this comes out
we should rename this to something that
is not the same as the function
has one
has one
yeah so this is a solved state this is
not the solved state
and back into the solid state so now we
can
add a check that is
started here so both of these need to be
true
so now it should have disappeared again
and
now that we have a started to be true
if it would be solved again now we would
get
the message back so i think we can say
that
is solved the win condition
is also finished now the next part
i think we should add some smooth
animations
install react motion
so now we have react motion installed
here
and we're going to use that in
our tile component
so let's import
motion and spring
from
react motion
so then we wrap this whole thing in a
motion
component
and we need to come up with this motion
style variable
to tell it how it should move
forward translate x and translate
y
so let's declare this
motion style variable
so we set translate
x is equal to wrap this is
in spring to get some nice bounciness to
it
and then we say visual position x
so inside motion we we create this
function and as inputs we get
the values that are gonna be animated
so i will move this closing to after
the ally
so instead of using the tile style here
now
we can use the values that
react motion gives us and they will be
animated over time
so let's see if anything changed now
no five minutes later
oh i'm stupid i stopped the bill to
install
the motion so stupid
don't be like me you have to be smarter
than me
i'm such an idiot sometimes
okay so now we have the new code running
and now it does work nice so this is
like
a little bit of a spring effect
that looks much better and now we should
do
the the most fun part of the build
to create the custom image for the
background
i think it will also be the most
challenging part but
i think it would be really cool if we
made it work
so let's go to the app here
and under the app
we should have an input component
and we need some state to keep track of
the
image url
use state
so cost image
image and set image
use state and let's set it
empty to begin with it's called image
url for clarity
so the value of this
is
and we need an unchanged
handle image
change
so let's create that function
valuable image change
and we get an event
so we set the image url
to e dot target dot
value to get the value from the input
box
and if we change that we want
the url
in the address bar to follow along with
it so we do
window dot history dot
replace state
we just pass empty strings for data and
title
and now for the url we're going to use
our helper function that i mentioned
import
update url what was the name of it
update url parameter
parameter from
there we go so here to get
the new url back we can do update url
parameters
and was the function was
url param and param value
so to get the your current url we can do
window.location.href
and the parameter name we can call that
image and the value
that is image url
or i guess no it's not image url
e e target value because the
we're just changing the image url here
so it's not changed yet so we instead of
image url
we do e target value here as well
so now we should update the state and we
update
also the url in the address bar
but we also need to have a use effect
because on-page loans
we want to take let's say that you pass
a link to your friend
with this specific image on page load we
need to update the react state
from the address bar if there is a image
url set
for that we're going to use a use effect
so we do use effect
and if since this is just going to be
called once
we put empty braces here
that will cause it to run once
so const url
ramps to get the url params we can do
new
url search params and
we pass in the window dot
location.search
so now we have an object here
so we can do if
url params has
image
then we know there's a value for us to
fetch we set
image url to
url params okay
image so then the game state should be
updated to the image
that we have the url for in
as a url parameter
um
here is an error
[Music]
hmm
okay let's see do we have any errors
update your parameter
what was it called then
okay big letters
what about now
okay the emojis should have span
roll image yeah
okay so now let's try it out so
here we see no url parameters yet
test image see once i started typing
there
it added a url parameter
called image and value is what i wrote
in the text box
so let's try to changed it and reload
the page and see if it gets
loaded in abcd
and reload yeah and it's being set
on page load here so that's perfect so
now
the last step is to take this image url
and place it as the background here in
the puzzle
but as you can see we can't just
fit it on all of this because it's
separate tiles
so we need to calculate small parts of
it
by using like the the background size
and background position of it
so i think again
we need to go into the tile style here
so we also need to pass in this
image url so pass it in here
image url is url
and also from board to tile
image
and we make sure that we
take it in here as well
and here
so now we have image url here in the
tile style
so we said background
image
is
and we need to wrap this in
since it's in css here we need to wrap
it like this
to tell css this is a url
and then we need to calculate the
background size
background size
so we do
first it's the width the background size
i guess
it should be
the board size
board size
in pixels
and now the trickiest part
causation
so we should do this in percent
so we'll do 100 divided by
grade size so 100
divided by 4
in percent so will be 25
and then we need to
we need to add 25 depending on
what the index is
so this will be 25 and we
multiply that by the x position
and to get the x position we need to do
index module grid size
which should still shift by 25
but
it should jump one spot for each four
increase by four of the index so
oops i'm i'm blocking it
grid size and then percent
what are the chances that this would
work
probably very slim
so now we should find a
square image since our board is square
we should use a square image
let's try this smiley one here copy
picture address let's make sure it works
yeah that work
that seems good we paste it here
it did not work so let's debug this
and see that we have
image url here console.log
images
we do have the image in the title
oh wait we're not adding these
to the tile style so instead of you
doing this
we can do
tile style we spread it
oh that is close
it's very close and
it does shift so we can't use the
index here we should we shouldn't use
the index we should use the
tile value because
that is the number that the tile has and
not the index
i'm blocking you again
and not the index we should use the tile
so now see now it sticks to
the tile number not the index
cool so
i have to try try this out
a bit
i think this will only work if it's just
for a grid by four
but for this tutorial let's just use
this
i think it's good enough right
so now i should be able to send this
link to a friend
and when they open it they get my custom
image and they can
start the game and then they can
play it and try to figure it out that's
awesome i think
i think we're actually done with the
game final this was a long
tutorial and it was quite confusing so
hopefully it made sense
time to time so if you enjoyed the video
please thumbs up the video make a
comment and also i was thinking since we
can share this puzzle
after i deploy it i will add the link to
the
live site in the description then we can
actually post links
in the comment and come up with really
fun
images to try to solve in this sliding
puzzle
so thanks for watching and i'll see you
in the next one
[Music]
you